So this is a conversation where I want to
see what you think.
I'm not suggesting I know what needs to happen.
I'm not suggesting any authoritarian tactics
by states.
I just want to see where you're at on this
issue.
Corona virus is exploding at the national
level.
Some states are doing well.
But when you look at the United States as
a country in total, our worst four days in
the United States in terms of new cases came
in the last five days.
So you go to the very beginning of the pandemic.
The four worst days in terms of new cases
have all happened in the last week.
And yet here in Massachusetts, we I'm so thrilled
to say we reported zero deaths yesterday for
the first time since the pandemic started.
And in fact, New England and New York and
New Jersey, this sort of eight state consortium,
these are some of the best places to be right
now in terms of the degree of reduction in
cases and transmission.
Vermont had no new cases yesterday.
New Hampshire had only 22.
Maine had only 34.
As I said, Massachusetts, zero deaths and
about 100 new cases.
Connecticut, about 150.
New York and New Jersey still with higher
case numbers, but dramatic reductions.
And again, relative to their population, the
numbers are not quite so scary.
So in terms of the consortium, our governor,
Charlie Baker, here has expanded the no quarantine
bubble to include New York, for example.
Now, you're going to be able to if you travel
from New York to Massachusetts, you're not
going to be required to quarantine for 14
days, assuming you meet certain requirements.
Masks are everywhere.
As many of you know, I've been in Martha's
Vineyard this week.
Everybody's just wearing masks.
You go everywhere.
It's mask, mask, mask.
You're not going anywhere and seeing people
without them.
But look at what's happening elsewhere.
You've got these huge swaths of red states,
plus California, which are seeing record cases.
You've got California, Texas, Florida, Arizona,
Georgia, the Carolinas, Tennessee, Louisiana,
Alabama, Ohio.
And at some point, you're only going to keep
that walled off for so long.
At some point, if the cases keep exploding
in certain parts of the country, the cases
will start going up here in the northeast.
You you have flights between these parts of
the country.
So-called mandatory quarantines are really
tough to enforce.
And people know it.
People aren't doing it.
So does the Northeast need to do something?
Because we we're hopefully looking at being
able to safely reopen schools in the fall
and do more.
But if the cases start bleeding over from
the more disastrous part.
The country, it's going to ruin the work we've
been doing for months at this point.
Again, reminder, I played this clip earlier,
I'll play it again.
Dr. Foushee is talking about 100000 new cases
a day in the U.S. if things don't turn around.
He says the infection rate is out of control
in some parts of the country.
Take a look at this clip one more time.
It is going to be very disturbing.
I will guarantee you that, because when you
have an outbreak in one part of the country,
even though in other parts of the country,
they're doing well.
They are vulnerable.
I made that point very clearly last week at
a press conference.
We can't just focus on those areas that are
having the surge.
It puts the entire country at risk.
We are now having 40 plus thousand new cases
a day.
I would not be surprised if we go up to 100000
a day if this does not turn around.
And so I am very concerned.
So what should the Northeast do?
I mean, legally, this is difficult.
The Constitution grants ingress and egress
to and from states.
And I am not proposing that we violate the
Constitution.
Airlines have shown they are committed to
having more flights and having flights be
more full.
So I don't know what, if anything, can be
done.
But if cases continue to explode to this degree
in some parts of the country, eventually the
pandemic is going to come back to the northeast
because people are traveling.
People are ignoring quarantine.
Can you do roadblocks?
But not to stop people from coming in merely
to register that they are coming in and ask
them, where will you be quarantining?
You still can't really enforce it.
You don't have the resources.
But maybe if people go through that, they
would be more mindful and maybe be more likely
to stick to the required quarantine.
I don't know.
It's obviously beyond the resources of any
state to really enforce it.
So I have no idea.
My question to you is, what should be done?
We are beyond the early hotspot phase.
The early hotspot phase was based on flights
and and the earlier spots of contagion.
You had hotspots.
It's now based on policy.
The places with the better policy are doing
better.
The places with the looser policy are doing
worse.
What should be done?
Should the Northeast do anything?
Let me know what you think and we'll have
more coverage of this on our Instagram page
at The David Pakman Show.